We've seen the rocket
equation, and we've
studied the example when
there's no external forces.
Now, let's consider an example
when the external force is not
0.
Well, one of our
examples is just a rocket
taking off in a
gravitational field.
And so when we want to focus
on the external forces,
let's draw our
rocket at time, t.
And now, consider-- what are the
force diagrams on this rocket?
Well, we have a
gravitational force, mg.
So we're going to
choose j hat up.
So now, what does our
rocket equation look like?
We wrote the exhaust
velocity as minus mu j hat.
And so if we write this now as
a vector equation in the j hat
component, we get minus mg.
We have the rate that the
rocket mass is changing,
and this is in our-- we
have this as-- remember,
dm dr/dt is going
to be negative.
So there's a minus.
And over here, we have another--
this is u because u is minus u.
And finally, we have
m rocket dvr/dt.
Now, once again, we're
going to try to integrate--
this is actually equal.
And we're going to try to
integrate this equation
to find a solution for the
velocity as a function of time
when all the fuel is burned.
So what we do is we'll
multiply through by dt,
and we have minus dmr
times u equals mr dvr.
And this is mass of the rocket.
And now, let's divide through
by mass of the rocket,
so we have minus g minus
dmr over mru equals dvr.
And once again, we can
integrate this equation
from some initial time
to some final time.
I'll just denote that by
i initial and i final,
and what we see here is we have
minus g times t final minus t
initial because
we're integrating
with respect to time.
Here, we're integrating mass,
so that's minus mu natural log.
And I'm going to write this
as mr final over mr initial.
And over here, we have vr
final minus vr initial.
And let's just
remove that time, t.
And so now, here is
our rocket equation.
Now, what we notice
here is-- let's look
at some rocket taking off.
So suppose that, at
10 initial equals 0,
we have the special condition
that vr initial equals 0
and mr initial equals the
mass of the rocket-- dry mass.
That's all.
That's not counting the fuel.
Plus the total mass of the fuel.
And the final-- at t final, when
the engine turns off-- we're
going to try to find
this velocity at t final.
And our condition
for the final mass
is all the fuel has been
burned, so this is just
the dry mass of the rocket.
And so what we get is
we get minus g t final.
Now, I'm going to
switch the sign here,
so we have-- if
I invert the log,
that will give a minus sign.
And I have plus u log of mr
of d plus mass of the fuel.
That's the initial
mass of the rocket.
Divided by just the
dry mass, and that's
equal to vr at t final.
So one of the interesting
questions that you might ask
is-- how fast should
you burn the fuel,
and what will that have to
do with the final speed?
So we can see from
this expression
that, if you burn the fuel for
a very long period of time--
so t final is big--
then this piece will
diminish the final velocity.
So if you want the fastest speed
after you've burned the fuel,
you want to burn the fuel so
that t final is as short as
possible.
We have the shortest
burn time, will give us
the largest velocity when
all the fuel has been burned.